having car microwave in the house Wow
oh my god I did a review of his book
your word I'm Zach that is amazing that
he's on the live stream Evans got like
six hundred billion followers that is so
cool
his book was so good on the one where it
my one word was inspire can only inspire
people to read books and travel the
world what you want to do to see the
book review of your one word go check
him go check that video out on my on my
channel also check out these videos what
is the one word that defines who you are
and what you stand for
in today's video I'm reviewing your one
word by Evan Carmichael
Evans got seven hundred thousand people
following him on on YouTube when I did
the book review I'm sure you had like
six hundred fifty thousand people
following you
yeah hashed I believe that is Evan's
Evan's one words you can use that in so
many ways it's book he said like it says
in the book the words that I use the
most are usually the best words I'm
super grateful and honored and humbled
that Evans in my live stream actually
taken me aback a little bit it all
started with books for me I didn't go
traveling I was out of shape I wasn't
doing well in school and books we
started that for me and I started
reading optics by my mind reading books
like your one word by Evan Carmichael
these kind of books have taught me to to
think in a way which is very different
from on the mainstream so I want to
spread that message
okay so Evan says spread the mission
people would love to hear you're
inspired journey I want to be a part of
it make them feel like that they're on
the journey with you yeah that 100% 100%
true
that's what I'm trying to do here with
you guys I want you guys to come on this
journey with me traveling and also we
have lots of cool books avinash it's a
good question for you one thing I am not
so you're worried about but something I
have to think about is ah when I go to
New Zealand obviously enough find the
jobs that I can support myself but you
have any ideas or any ways for me to be
able to work army from my laptop or
anything like that I'll be really useful
is Evan still in the building
let me know if you're still in building
of them but thank you so much for
popping into my screen and to my stream
Evan still here Evan do you have any
opportunities for me are working for you
remotely because I remember in the book
you said that your team works for you
from remotely and they're actually
travelling the world I remember that
clearly because you're you got a quite
young team and they wants to go
travelling if you have any opportunities
or if you know any ways for me to make
money while I'm on the go so I can
support my travels let me know that's
interesting yes it depends on what value
you can bring Brett it was all about
value it's all about value that's what
Evan thank you so much for dropping in
this live stream go ahead and pick up
the way I don't you don't to be late for
her do you don't want to be late thanks
drop it in heavens in a bit guys I am
God
I'm sitting in a confidence in comments
oh my god guys ever be is so successful
yes the doctor a comedy that happened to
me on my first ever stream Evan had like
a reach of millions of people around the
world and he had done what I wanted to
do the fact that he dropped into my live
stream is incredible what I screaming
ask is crazy what kind of body can I
bring some guys I mean he will be able
to it he's the kind of guy who can you
know offer so much opportunity oh okay
ever that is so funny I bet he's still
watching this as well there he said that
he's left ah I hope I said Queen I think
I'm sure he did he's probably still
watch now yeah serious though he said
nice things don't judge don't worry so
this has been so much fun and the funny
thing is is that that I was [ __ ]
myself before I came on this livestream
else so nervous because it is all
unedited and I've never done anything
like this before and I think anyone was
going to pop into this conversation so
just going to be me talking to myself so
just goes to show you that if you you
know do the things that scare you and
you get the rewards and what happens
we've had you know 20 25 people war
friends and book to get into
conversation is talking about a recall
topic and then having someone like Evan
pop in is just the bonus
you